so just to quickly review what we did
last time
look at the Equality function where
Alice and Bob both have strings of
length N and they need to determine if
the two strings are equal and showed
that the deterministic complexity
communication complexity of the Equality
function I said n but actually it was n
plus 1 because of the way I define the
protocol and there was also a lower
bound of n plus I surface and then we
talked about randomized
communication complexity and there are
two kinds we private coins and the
public coins and we saw that any public
coin protocol can be converted to a
private coin protocol with an additional
investment of login bits in
communication this was new months
theorem and we examined the communic the
randomized communication complexity of
the Equality function in the two models
so in the public coins model
and we could drive down the error to
something like one or two to the K with
K bits of communication whereas in the
private coins
let's say yeah so I said that this is
actually tight there is a lower bound of
log in even with constant error
probability okay so what we right here
is the probability of error and the
superscript tells us whether we are in
the public coin model or the private
coin mode then yeah so
this is what we stopped with that is
Alison Bob have two strings and they
differ that's the promise and they need
to communicate in order to determine the
leftmost position where they differ and
there was a knife protocol by repeatedly
using equality and we saw that that had
communication complexity something like
log n Times log log n the second log log
n was essentially there to drive the
probability down but you could somehow
set up a tree walking algorithm and that
algorithm work better and we were able
to show let's say four I'm just going to
call it leftmost actually doesn't matter
what is private or public let's say
private and let's say the error is nice
neck
so after the talk many people ask me
about this and yeah thank you for asking
and of course the reason you asked me
was there the presentation was deficient
but I'm very encouraged and I'm so I'm
going to change my plans today so I was
planning to tell you some general things
about compression etc but instead I
think everybody likes a concrete example
and I'm just going to tell you a lower
bound for what's called the disjoint is
function using the information
complexity method ok so I'm going to
tell you what the disjoint is problem is
it's a very important problem in
communication complexity it has many
applications and my plan is to come back
on Friday and show you how this join
this means many things okay so yeah
what's the disjoint us problem
friends Alice has a subset bob has a
subsidy and the task is to determine yes
the intersection t once again so when I
say that Alice has a subset of 1 to n we
could think of Alice's input as the
characteristic vector of this set and
Bob's input as the characteristic vector
of the same T and they need to
communicate in order to determine if
there is a position where they both have
what ok that's the complement of this
problem that is the set intersection
problem and if they don't have any such
position where they both have once then
we say that the sets are disjoint
so let's see
domestic complexity of the set dis join
us problem so
consider the following special inputs
so we give a set s to Alice and to Bob
we give exactly the compliment of that's
it so the number of such inputs is 2 to
the n then
so each such input of resides in a
different rectangle okay so for example
if there were two sets s1 s1 compliment
and s2 s2 complement and they had the
same transcript then you could cut and
paste and show that there is an input
where the two sets are actually
intersecting and they still have the
same transcript but of course
intersecting sets and non intersecting
sets are required to give different
answers so this is very similar to what
we did for the Equality function for
equality function we showed that all the
inputs which reside on the diagonal they
must have their own private transcript
they cannot share transcripts and as a
result there was a large number of
leaves in our protocol tree and since
the protocol tree had many leaves it had
to be tall okay the same thing happens
here we have 2 to the N such special
inputs and each of them requires a
different rectangle what you said not
carefully argue why they must have
different rectangles but you can say so
this looks for the moment yeah
so the deterministic complexity of this
joint pneus of n you can c plus one and
of course we can always solve any
problem by one party sending the entire
input to the other so
case of the Equality function there was
a dramatic drop in communication when we
went from deterministic two randomized
and so far a deterministic lower bound
looks pretty similar to the lower bound
that we used for the quality function
but turns out that for dis join us we do
not have such efficient randomized
protocols and in fact there's a theorem
of
shows that the randomized complexity
let's say even with
so this is
right foot
so yes there was the original proof of
kalyanasundaram n [ __ ] and it was based
on coal magrav complexity which is
information theory in a certain
computational way and then this theorem
this proof was simplified by Roseboro
and it was really put in a completely
information theoretic framework okay by
bar Yoseph jai Ram Kumar and Shiva Kumar
and it is this proof that I am going to
describe today goal today is chest to
understand this why is it that the
disjoin is function even with
randomization needs linear amounts of
communication
so I really would like people to ask
questions I mean really like this
theorem and this approach and just yeah
hope that you also like it at the end we
will say trials are public it doesn't
matter but right now let me assume that
it is private thank ya so we at the
moment don't promise anything about the
size of the sets they're allowed to yeah
so they were just been told that they
will receive some sets and they need
there are versions of the dis join us
function which have applications in
various areas especially data structures
where to control the size of the sets is
important okay and then we get other
bounds again many of those techniques
are based on information here but you
just see this today Chris yeah so
yesterday was one half why is it now
one-third sorry so yesterday you start
up with saying that you could get one
half they can get one half to the power
K right yeah so why is it now becoming
one third here when I just write that
one half but doesn't matter on yes so
one half is so if I write one half I
mean I shouldn't have written one half
yesterday either because you can always
get any problem right with probability
half without communication by just
tossing a coin okay but that was one
half in a special way for inputs which
were equal okay we made no error at all
and inputs which are unequal were caught
with probability half it was a one-sided
error with one-half which we could
amplify and you know we could reduce the
probability of n okay so let's say that
on every input your probability of error
can be at most one third very soon I'm
going to make it worse we will see ya so
this one third is on every input
a randomized protocol means given any
input they the two players play they
reach a leaf and they give out that
answer that answer should be correct
with probability two-thirds for every
input so I just look at this is going to
be on one side of error also as good
with you son people since we it's a
lower bound will proudly prove it for
two sided edit
is it so just a little bit different but
so here the your crack is always
randomized protocol but worst case on
the input right that's right does it
make sense to also look at a
probabilistic inputs it for exam S&T are
randomly chosen success that's right so
yeah now you then the complexity will
start determined depending on the
distribution you use okay and so there
is something called the distributional
complexity and it is closely tied to
randomize complexity using duality okay
and that is the traditional way of
showing lower bounds for randomized
complexity okay but we will talk about
distributions on inputs but
distributional complexity will not
explicitly play a role in today's proofs
okay but yeah so that is a very
important way of thinking about problems
especially randomized communication
complexity and I expect maybe tomorrow
we will see some of it because that
would be asked what I sort of a
classical information theorist we think
of right the source yeah coming from a
certain distribution that you want to
find a capacity in terms of that
distribution oz that's right so here we
are the worst case yeah and we want the
protocol yeah but very soon yeah I think
getting reach your comfort zone it's
okay I'm coming over this also planned
this
so yeah n equals 1 okay so Edison Bob
have
thinking of them as sets in a universe
of size 1 i'm just going to think of
alice being given a bit and bob has been
given a bit and they need to compute
they need to check if both of them are
one
so i'll be switching between disjoint
pneus and intersection I mean compute
and a of B that means the two sets
intersect
now okay so we will try to analyze the
communication complexity of this problem
I mean it almost looks silly I mean you
have to send at least one bit yeah and
what more is there to say but the main
attraction of information theory for us
is that you can also say things like
half a bit and one-fourth of a bit yeah
and things like that and what we will
actually prove for this baby problem the
problem of N equals one is that you need
some amount of information to be
transmitted transferred from Alice to
Bob okay and how much information Alice
sends to Bob will depend on the error
she's alone ok so right now we are going
to be really harsh we are going to say
solve this problem with probability of
error less than half minus epsilon so we
are now analyzing the and function Alice
and Bob both have bits they need to
compute the end of the two bits and they
need to design a protocol where they get
the answer right with probability just a
little bit over half half plus epsilon
and we want to understand how hard this
problem is
so yeah they have their protocol tree
and at the end they reach a leaf and
they declare either one or zero so buy
em a bee I mean the transcript on input
that's the leaf that you reach now if
they turn into just compute a and B at
the end of a be but we allow them to
have a huge protocol yeah but what are
we trying to measure
sure the following that in any protocol
which achieves error less than this the
following is true
give Bob the input zero and very Alice's
input so then I write capital X here x
is uniformly distributed bit which is 0
or 1 now a particular transcript results
that means when Bob is given 0 and alice
is given X a certain distribution on
Leafs arises and then Alice's input is
changed from 0 to 1 a different
distribution perhaps already and if the
two distributions are very similar that
means Alice has not leaked too much
information about her input because
looking at the transcript we are not
able to guess what she had and similarly
we are looking at the situation where
Alice as a zero and Bob's input varies
and we are asking how much information
does the transcript have about boxing
now these are so I want to spend some
time on this these are inputs in which
the value of the function they are
trying to compute is known and is 0 ok
now if and is 0 now so let's see bob has
a zero is it necessary that Alice give
any information those that the answer is
you well this is a protocol that is
correct on all inputs ok even 11 but we
are just going to analyze it on these
special inputs ok this is what so
strange if you look at the deterministic
complexity that's what we did we
analyzed the problem only on inputs that
word is joint yeah I mean for all of
them the answer was the same ok so we're
doing the same sort of thing here we are
analyzing this problem on inputs for
which the answer is known the answer is
0 now just want to tell you why we there
must be some sort of a lower bound on
this information complexity so suppose
it was the case that this is very small
that means then bob has a zero Alice's
message doesn't depend on her input yeah
whether you give her a 0 or a 1 sheeps
roughly sends the same thing to Bob ok
all right now let's see what Bob does
when alice is 0 Bob
will not give different responses to
else
No
suppose that is the case now suppose we
give both parties one imagine suppose
this number was very small and now we
give both parties one ad is his first
message now she is worried maybe bob has
a zero so I should not reveal too much
information so Alice input is the same
as sorry Alice's message will not depend
on her input it will not vary with her
input because she hasn't yet learned
that bob has a one but having received
this useless message from Alice Bob
cannot give too much information to
Alice either because from what he can
tell Alice has a zero and this protocol
will not go too far even though they
have won the transcripts will continue
to look as if they both had zeros ok and
then but we know that in the case of two
zeros being given and two ones being
given the distributions must differ
significantly because in one case the
answer is supposed to be one and in the
other case the answer is you this is the
rough intuition and this can finally be
proved as this one so now I'm just going
to sort of put this away and let us say
we believe this and yeah turns out that
the main proof your question so we are
assuming private realm of the Spirit so
again now so X is a random variable by
design we are going to choose it 0 or 1
this M is a random variable for various
reasons ok I mean it marries for various
reasons one is because X itself varies
the other is that Allison Bob somehow
have this urge to use their private coin
tosses to do different things even
though their input is fixed so yeah
personal issue so the I ha yep so yeah
so the mutual information between a
random variable X and then is entropy of
X plus the entropy of M minus the
entropy of X might as well write it as H
of X minus H of X so how much
information at the end how much does the
entropy of X drop was the condition on
it ok now this also for some reason is
the same as so I'm here we are using the
sorry something wrong so in this lemma
just random variable because 11 never
suited to know that that is m 11 alright
so somehow the entire also this m is the
transcript of this protocol and this
protocol computes the and for all inputs
this lemma thought of users to fathom is
a transcript but yes fracture because
the m100 & M on 11 must be different
right yes question is what's essential
property of em are you actually using
this lemma does have to be a transcript
hopefully this be truthful a more
general family funnel Berbers somehow
taken into a closet em on 11 should be
different from I 100 no I hope we will
prove this lemma towards the end yeah
and then let's first see what is used
here at the moment it uses a moment just
the property that the rectangle property
of protocol so it depends very strongly
on the fact that these this M is a
transcript
well so what's the plan the plan is to
now do general n
we did N equals one and already I had to
wave my hand so much and so it turns out
that what we will do is the following we
will show that yes let me just
you
so the plans this is say okay take any
protocol for the disjoint asst function
and let's say the protocol solves the
dis join us function with probability of
error bounded away from half half minus
epsilon and it has communication see now
this this is a protocol which works on n
bit inputs now using this protocol will
show that there is a protocol for just
the and function
at this I'm function
the protocol for the and function will
be set up just to satisfy what we needed
here that is it will continue to have
small error and we will not be talking
about communication we will show that
this protocol achieves small error
without leaking too much information if
the original protocol was efficient then
the information leaked in this protocol
is also small but we know that no
protocol no decent protocol for and can
get away with small amount of
information leak so we will just equate
Ansari compare this with epsilon square
we get that is the plan so
no steps one is how is this reduction
achieved and then why is this true Chris
so now I'm first going to do this and
then you pissed about so then I said
this I meant this I thought yeah so this
is already so yea yea i meant yep so
yeah listen you're not giving your
engines yeah yeah I'm not
so yeah
looking for distributions on inputs
we're going to do to the end of them
yeah so
takes a particular protocol for the
disjoint us function and we test it
against various distributions okay so
yes I'm going to tell you how this
distribution is set up so
there is something called Sigma which
indexes the distribution so Sigma will
be a string in a B to the N so there are
2 to the n such strings for each of them
there is a distribution is go to the end
such distributions now how does this
Sigma determine the inputs for Alice and
Bob so Sigma is a sequence like this a
be a be ok so let me just call this the
activation pattern
never been used before I am just making
it up yeah activation pattern yeah so if
it is a in the first position that means
Alice's input is chosen randomly as 0
and 1 and Bob's input you see
if it is B then Alice's input is random
Bob's input sorry what it is Bob's input
is random Alice's input is 0 who is and
then be in each coordinate one player
has an active input and the other player
has 0 again it suffers from the same
sort of deficiency that is on every
input that is going to come up in this
distribution the value of the disjoint
is function is determined the sets that
are being generated are disjoint why
because one of them is committing to a
zero and no matter what the other
fellows input is it's never going to
intersect is this little so yeah so such
an input i'm going to call this x sigma
and y sigma so yeah x sigma is this
vector Y Sigma is this way
so all right and we feed this to our
protocol and we look at this quantity I
of
ok
little information between Alice's input
and the transcript
this quantity so the mutual information
is at most the entropy of em and for us
M is a sea bit string
this clip we're just going to write em
it's understood that ok so maybe issue
so the amount of information that Alice
leaks about her input in the message m
yeah it's all bounded by sea
and we have a similar inequality
football
so if we take the average sorry you
using the ingredients good yeah so here
for this to be true the notice that the
once we have we're talking about fixed
Sigma in this Sigma the excise are all
independent and when the excise are all
independent this inequality holds okay
say this is less than equal to C
and similarly
newcondition area might pass when it
goes up and it's 0 and so it should go
the other way so you either than it
already or that's a minus sign breaks in
the mutual commitment so the conditional
entropy has a minus sign in the making a
big mistake mutual information is
correct I think it's well if this is
wrong in good time so if if the excise
are independent the the h of x sigma
will split exactly as equality and the
negative term is where you get the
nativity I think it's alright anything
I'm sorry automated
check this oh sorry so fix a protocol
with communication see okay so end and
then I want to show this okay so it is
this implication that we are working on
first I agree with charger I also think
it should be the other direction because
when you expand with chain rule and you
get the egg valleys in the conditioning
and by independence you can bring a man
on the right hand side select see x1 x2
xn yeah so sorry this is mutual
information then X x1 x2 xn minus H of X
1 X 2 X n
yes yeah and this is the sum of the edge
of excise yeah and
you
if I replace this by summation H of X I
givin em then i right this guy's course
is it okay so I at least one person
agrees it's
just check something wrong yes yes yes
yes so maybe I should I should yes I if
I put a sigma you will assume that it
was meant to be yeah yeah so whenever
there is a sigma around assume that it
is X Sigma and y sigma that are being
fed into the protocol and the transcript
is being examined so you have these two
inequalities and just i'll divide by n
and start writing this as expectation
yeah so expectation over the choice
maybe I should not mess this up like
this expectation over the choice of I I
x sigma i colon and sigma plus expect
vice sigma i call em sigma is less than
to see
so can ask a good question miss Tucker
looks like both your llama and
everything you've said so far can be
actually replaced instead of em you just
bought leaf yeah so leaf and transcript
are the same thing because in a protocol
the leaf determines sorry I yeah I
should have just said one thing I've
said both leaf and transcript but as far
as information is concerned day one
determines the other question so this is
true for every Sigma so I put this this
is still true
and whenever you see to expectations you
should expect to switch them and so we
write expectation over I and then
expectation over Sigma of
and see what
so this expectation is bounded by to see
over N so there must be yeah implies
that there exists an eye for which this
quantity is bounded by 20 now that is
the week coordinate okay so let me just
wave my hands now okay but we get back
to concrete things very soon so what are
we looking for we have this protocol for
the dis join us function we have done
some calculations and we have found a
coordinate time where it looks like the
communication is not paying too much
attention to the i8 coordinate yeah so
she now any dis join us function is a
bunch of ants you want to know whether
the end of this bit and this bit is one
whether the end of this bitten this beat
is one and if even one of them is one
the two sets intersect okay so what we
have done so far is found one week
coordinate okay what we are going to do
is there is this lets l-little Alice and
little bomb who kind of play with tiny
inputs ok now we are going to embed this
problem in the ayat coordinate and
somehow use what we have just proved
here to conclude that sorry that this is
true and don't take my constants I leave
a space here for the constant say so
yeah but never fill them up ok so yeah
so there will be tues there will be
fours and various things yeah but we
have we will have proved that we have
found a protocol for the and function
where the corresponding information is
bounded by C over
let's do that carefully so we have fixed
an eye so should I call that I hat
sorry another question yeah it looks
like it could work for public around
school did we ever use and yes so I go
correlation doctors okay you need to be
so public randomness will work but then
here i will have to add the shared
randomness explicitly yeah no no there's
yeah so just keeping it simple with
tribe that's all yeah i see theorem and
the proof is just probably yeah in any
case we know that we can translate
public to private with an additional
login and
fixed this high hat and this has gone
away and this quantity is bounded by to
see over n now what is this expectation
of a sigma let's look at our inputs
this I hat has been chosen and this is
where eventually a and B are going to
come and say and then there is the Sigma
which tells us who's got the active
input in each coordinate ok now this
Sigma tells us who's got the active
input in the first coordinate the second
coordinate third coordinate etc now the
Sigma I can think of as consisting of
Sigma I that is who's got the active
input in this soil I had can I just
leave it as I yep the eye and Sigma
minus i by sigma minus I I mean who's
got the active input in the remaining
coordinate that's what Sigma minus I
tells us this so now this is an
expectation over everything so I can
also fix
sigma minus sign so let me just say that
here so for one value of Sigma minus I
this quantity is still true so let's say
in the first coordinate alice is active
in the second coordinate bob is active
in the third coordinate again bob is
active and so on
now in this I have still not done
anything so what we know is that
expectation over Sigma I yeah the others
have been fixed the two
Sigma plus I Y Sigma i M Sigma is less
than C oh now if you compare this
quantity with this quantity yeah what
does this mean this says
okay so come back to this comparison our
goal was to extract a protocol for the
and function okay so here is my protocol
for the end function you've been given
this input and here was this protocol
where Alice and Bob were waiting for
their input ok this is the protocol for
this join us ok with communication see
once you are given this a and B what you
do is in the is coordinate which I the
special I that was found put a and B and
then in all these places you fill it up
using Sigma minus I ok that is give zero
to one of the parties and the other
party you just toss a random coin so
this particular input can be generated
by Alice herself she doesn't need
cooperation from Bob because that Sigma
minus I has been fixed and similarly
this particular input can be generated
by bomb he feeds it sorry they both feed
this input into this big protocol
protocol runs it's a protocol for dis
join us it doesn't know that it is being
made to work so hard to just compute an
end of two bits let it run and then
eventually it gives an answer you
declare that to be the answer
you should call on to bits now the
question is does it compute the and
function correctly well the original
protocol was computing that is Jonas
function correctly with probability half
minus epsilon there is no question of
intersection in the other coordinates
and if a and B are both 1 then the two
sets intersect otherwise they don't so
let you confirm that this protocol
computes the end with probability half
minus yeah I'm almost convinced with
this there's still the air the original
was you know small that then you did you
picked a special I did all these other
things doesn't that perfectly so I've
always been working with the
expectations okay so no so at the moment
this is a so I am done nothing to the
original protocol this is all in
analyzing the properties of this and
protocol I take the original protocol I
feel it give it an input it is duty
bound to give me the correct answer with
probability half minus a half plus
epsilon on every input yep so this is a
particular input with originals all this
is calculation yeah the protocol doesn't
question so when you decide on a safe
yeah it's you're not taking that into
communication account no no yeah sorry
district so Alice and Bob they were
given this protocol they said they
analyzed they find out aha this is the V
coordinate of this protocol then they
say okay what Sigma minus I should we
choose they do this calculation they
found out on there is a sigma minus sign
they've hardwired this into their system
then work and receive that inputs little
a and little B which I have erased and
then sorry here little a and little B
they plug it in here they just had this
fixed Sigma minus I use that to fill up
the rest of the input and then start off
the big Alison Big Bob who actually
meant to compute disjoint nasaan n big
functions but nevertheless whatever
answer they give they declare that to be
the answer for the end function I was
Tobias MX coma zero sorry so yeah so but
at least okay so there are many things
to prove so this computes the and with
error probability half minus epsilon
that is all right okay now does this
inequality have anything to do with this
inequality that's your question yeah
okay so what does this inequality say
when okay so by the way what sort of a
protocol is this all this is going to be
treated as private randomness or else it
was input for the big Alice but for this
small else it is private randomness and
similarly this part is private
randomness there might be more private
randomness which the original protocol
itself had
this is rationale for Alice needing to
use a private random this is up like a
stand-in for channel noise so if you
stood for channel said why does Allison
user private randoms so we're in this
here why is she plugging in private
randomness here why doesn't she go with
a fixed input is that what you're saying
for the for the small and problem yes it
is such a stupid question but why not
just say oh I have zero oh I have one
okay so not and why use private
Randleman to solve that part in that
case Alice will be leaking a lot of
information yeah if she just declares
her input okay what we are saying is
that if you had a efficient protocol for
this Jonas you can cook up and a
protocol for the ANC's unction which is
information efficient okay still
communication wise it's a huge protocol
I mean it's embarrassing to have such
big protocols to compute and function
but we are not counting communication we
accounting information okay so yeah let
me just go back to your question what is
this this says if Bob is fed 0 what is
the amount of information about the bit
x which is a single bit and the
transcript and look at this contribution
here
so what does this count so when we fix
Sigma minus I and we very Sigma I of the
time we are counting this contribution
and half the time we are counting this
contribution so actually we will have
proved this this inequality with a
further factor of 2 so it's actually for
C over n I let you check this it needs a
little bit of thought so yep all right
so this is how we show that we can embed
the and function for two bits into that
is join us function and if only we could
prove this lemma will be done ok so I'll
take a couple of more minutes and
quickly tell you why this lemma is drew
questions I mean questions about the
strategy ok so what did we do saying the
same thing thinking and again we had a
protocol for this joint pneus we ran it
on these two to the N distributions of
input the do and then we isolated a
particular Sigma minus I and so that
alice is not leaking too much
information about her info what's the
point Alice has a small message to send
of see bits and she is being distracted
by all these inputs that are wearing it
could be that she is conveying
information about all of them they are
independently varying a small message
cannot convey information about a lot of
varying inputs in the same way bob has a
lot of varying in and our calculation
shows that there must be a coordinate
that both of them are neglecting in
their dis join us protocol and that will
lead to a contradiction
but so why is this true
so I think yeah before anybody can find
for the forces you raise your choice
yeah sorry i guarded now yeah that's
raised recorded to let me just turn yep
what's happening
if analyzing the baby problem n equals 1
ok Alice has could have zero or one both
could have zero or one and when Alice
has zero and zero there is a certain
transcript that there is a certain
distribution so they have a big protocol
tree where the inputs are just single
bit inputs and when this input is
received namely both get 0 then a
certain distribution on leaves is
generated and it is a distribution on
leaves because it's a randomized
protocol yeah similarly here you have
no then bob has a zero
anas doesn't reveal too much information
about whether she has a 0 or a 1 I mean
that is the content of this being small
this quantity is bounded by let us say
Delta and this quantity let's say is
also bounded by Delta if this quantity
is bounded by Delta then this
distribution and this distribution would
look roughly the same
similarly when for so when Alice has a
zero Bob does not reveal too much
information so these two are very close
that is because this is so now we have
to work with the right distance measure
so it turns out that a good distance
measure to use here is the Hellinger
distance between distributions ok so
yeah it is next time if there is
interest i will tell you so these two
are close these two are closed they're
closed by about something like square
root delta square root delta in some
distribution we can quantify that now by
triangle inequality these two
distributions so the set of transcripts
the distribution on transcripts
generated when this input is given and
this input is given is they're the same
ok so sorry that these two distributions
are very close now there is this little
terms up okay so how do we measure
distribution so you have what's the
distribution it is a probability vector
P 1 P 2 so on till p and if there r l
leaves now we actually just put square
roots on all the P is so that it becomes
a unit vector in square and add them
it's one now so basically we are
representing every probability
distribution as a point on the way okay
and the distance the Hellinger distance
is roughly the distance between these
two and you can imagine that this
distance is closely related to the dot
product
so if two distributions are closed there
dot products must be large okay so these
two have these two distributions have
large dot products now because we are
talking about transcripts it turns out
that the dot product of these two
distributions is exactly the same as the
dot product of these two distributions
just accept this on faith yep the dot
product on these two distribution of
this distribution this distribution is
exactly the same as the dot product of
this distribution in this district after
taking square roots which means that
these two distributions also have high
dot product that means they have small
distance this is what we wanted to prove
if it were the case that this distance
is small this distance is small then
this distance will be small which means
this distance will be small and if this
distance is small on the input 0 0 and
11 Alice and Bob are roughly doing the
same thing they are not allowed to do
the same thing because in one case the
answer is 0 the other case the answer is
1 just tell you why you might expect the
dot product to be the same if you look
at a particular leaf and ask what is the
probability that a protocol fix an input
X for Alice and y for ball what is the
protocol what is the probability that
the protocol gets here it's a product of
two numbers so yesterday we check that
the inputs that reach here form a
rectangle and today just all right
what's the probability that you reach
you well there were alice's coordinates
and in those coordinates Alice should go
in the right direction and then there
were those places where Bob had to take
an action
so the probability or let us say tau 0 0
of L is actually a product of
what's the probability that Alice would
like to go down this path whenever she
is given a choice to decide and what's
the probability that Bob will go down
this path and so these numbers have this
product form there's a contribution from
Alice and a contribution from ball okay
so 00 has a contribution from Alice a
contribution from a bob 11 has a
contribution from Alice and contribution
from ball now if you just rearrange
those contributions take the zero
contribution of Alice and one
contribution of Bob you get this and you
take the other pair you get this and if
you turn out that this this is I mean if
it's it's an equality so it can't be
very deep yeah okay so yeah so just yeah
yeah manipulate it and figure it up okay
all right i went over time i am very
sorry yeah yeah so I can answer
questions but this all i have to say at
the moment any quick question right no
it's not tight sorry that's another
thing so there are more sophisticated
versions of this argument so this
epsilon square i do not know the main
bound for this join us with half minus
epsilon it's epsilon n is known ok
instead of epsilon squared in question
why didn't your conscious at the
difference between x and y are you in x
and y mucho information between edge and
right yeah so yeah so actually I the way
it is set up there is no single
probability space in which both x and y
live this quantity is computed once yes
but in that case I mean x and y are
independent so the mutual information
the price that should forget at the end
of the protocol at the end of the
protocol at the end of the protocol so
wherever you have a one yeah something
about the other person's bike since
there are whenever there is a one both
we know that both parties have
deterministic inputs 10 because it's a
randomized protocol we learn something
yeah I need to think obvious that too
complex to take order n because wherever
you have a bunch done but the other
person test that you have continued
proportional a number of mass which is
proportional to the length of the
sequence yeah so it sounds convincing I
just want to know why this is different
from equality in the Equality case also
they have em bit inputs and yeah so yeah
so I just need to know because question
I want to ask ya sorry an yeah maybe
yeah I'm I only asked for question yeah
okay any more question so one quick
question yeah so the flavor this proof
seems but kept close to classical
information theory which is you're
getting with the communication problem
for example over very long block many
symbols n large but then the end you
reduced to a single letter
characterization we just what happens
about one channel use is there some
deeper so there are these problems could
be direct some problems where you have a
certain complexity for a single version
of the problem and then if you try to
repeat them is it true that the
communication complexity scales linearly
with n and these are the questions that
aha we'll talk about tomorrow yeah i
think this
calder economical laboratory it's
exactly the same okay here is that we
should have a board to write down these
translation language what you doing
there was the bhattacharya parameters
bateria parameter sorry Hillinger thing
which there's a button sorry that my
mess hall is a charge for amateur okay
now we're in camas oh ok sorry no thanks